[Music]
hello everyone
so today we are going to begin our
discussion of the new chapter of 2d
elasticity
now it may seem a little bit odd to
apparently go back to 2d elasticity
after we have studied so much
about the three-dimensional versions of
various theories involving stresses and
strains
but there is a reason for it you see
there are a number of
problems of practical engineering
interest
which even though in reality they are
very much three-dimensional
can be with a little uh imagination
and a little uh simplification
of using modeling assumptions
can be very well reduced to from 3d
elasticity to 2d elasticity and the
first
uh broadly there are two
two ways in which we can do that so one
of them is plain stress
and other is plain strain and i'm sure
that
many of you by now uh having completed
a few years of undergraduate studies
already uh
are somewhat familiar with plane stress
and plane stream
but uh what we'll do in the first part
of this uh
as part of our discussions of 2d
elasticity is to go a little deeper into
these plane stress and plane strain
uh considerations and look at them uh
in more detail so first up is plane
stress
so
the canonical example when we talk about
plain stress
is this kind of a very thin
plate
so this is a very thin plate and
so i can depict its
thickness a slightly exaggerated fashion
in this way
uh now
geometrically it may seem simple enough
that okay
we have this uh kind of flat bleed
situation
which is very thin and that's what we
need for plane stress
but there are a number of important
considerations which one must be kept in
mind
especially at this level of study so uh
we'll state them formally uh and i think
will be faster if i just uh
if i just type them out so
the first consideration is that as you
can see
that that our domain is bounded
by two parallel planes okay
now this seems very obvious but let's
build up to
more complicated things slowly next also
because we are stating things formally
the distance between
these two planes is
very small compared to
the other dimensions of the domain okay
next uh what we'll consider is
so this is this is where we start
talking about the reference coordinate
system
okay so uh what we'll say is that
we'll fix up our x y plane
uh to be at the mid height of
this uh domain okay so
we'll will depict the
the x-axis like this
and the y-axis like that
and please note that although it may
appear that this xy plane
uh this this x axis and this y axis
they are lying on the top surface of
this domain
but actually i i mean uh then to be
present
at the mid height of this domain and
that height is taken
to be twice h okay so this height
this height is twice h
the top surface is at y is at z equal to
plus h
and the bottom surface is at z equal to
minus h
so
this is what we are going to write next
so the two planes are at
uh let me write that
or it's z equal to plus minus h
next up
and this is very very important the two
planes
at z equal to plus h and z equal to
minus h
they are stress free okay
basically the the condition that we are
actually saying
is that the
fraction there is zero but
we can write them in terms of the
stresses in this fashion
that sigma z is equal to sigma zx is
equal to sigma z y
or y z
is equal to zero
the next point is uh very interesting
in the sense that
this is where one of our simplifying
modeling assumptions
coming okay so what we say is that
there is little variation in uh in the
sigma zz
sigma zx and the sigma yz
to the thickness in fact it is all right
to approximate that to be zero through
the entire domain
okay so there is
very little variation in
sigma z sigma zx
and sigma why is it
the thickness
uh in fact
these will be approximated
to be zero okay so the three components
sigma z sigma zx and sigma yz
although perfectly speaking or ideally
speak strictly speaking they are not
zero to the domain to the thickness of
this domain
but they can be approximated to be zero
furthermore in a similar vein what we'll
say is that
again because of the thickness because
of the very small thickness
or
or rather just the thinness the other
non-zero components
okay the the non-zero components
uh will also have
very little variation
in the z direction
so what we mean to say is that if we
take
sigma xx sigma x y and sigma yy
they will have their functional
dependence
only on x and y okay so
sigma xx is a function of
x and y
sigma yy is a function
of x and y
similarly sigma x y okay so these are
the three
stress components that are non-zero
unlike sigma z sigma y z and sigma zx
and uh these will have a functional
dependence
only on x and y again based on the fact
that the the thickness of this
domain is very very small
the next one has to do the next
consideration we are going to state
again has to do with the
has to do with the loading so
what we'll say is that
in order to maintain this kind of a
stress field that is independent of z
okay so you see whether it is zero or
non-zero
the various stress components are
independent of z
okay so uh in order to
have these
presses to be independent of z
we must not have
uh any body forces
or tractions basically any kind of
loading uh
in the z direction
okay and the last one is that
the
the uh
the non-zero body forces attractions
wherever wherever they are
uh they must be independent
offset
it is also possible that they can be
symmetric about
the mid plane but we are not going to
write that down
okay so what you see uh as uh with
reference referring to this figure is
that
basically our loading should be like
this
okay so our loading should be in plane
okay so this loading maybe i can draw
that in a slightly better fashion
so it can be like that
uh it can be like that or like that
okay so all of these blue lines blue
arrows that i'm drawing
you you understand that they are
acting parallel to the x y plane
all of these blue lines are acting
parallel to the x y plane
they do not have any component in the z
direction
and say and they also do not have any
variation in the z direction
now with these considerations
uh in our hand uh what can we
actually do regarding the mathematical
formulation
okay what simplification does these
initial considerations
uh allow us so in order to look at that
let us go to the next page
so first of all what we'll do is we'll
take a look at
the constitutive behavior okay or the
material behavior
we already have discussed this
in detail in the previous chapter on
material behavior
so
so from constitutive law basically what
we are going to
say is that we are going to
use a material which is linear elastic
isotropic
so we are only going to
consider the generalized hooke's law and
we know that epsilon xx is equal to 1 by
e
sigma xx minus nu sigma yy
up plus sigma zz
now please note that sigma zz is zero
okay so this is simply epsilon x x is
equal to one by
sigma x x minus nu sigma y y similarly
for epsilon y y
we have one by e sigma y y
minus nu sigma x x plus
sigma z z and again the sigma z z is
also zero
all right next for epsilon z said
what we'll have is rather interesting
you see here sigma zz minus nu
sigma xx plus sigma yy
now this sigma z that is zero but that
does not mean
that our epsilon z z is zero in fact it
is not zero
because we will not not expect that
sigma x
x plus sigma yy is going to be zero in
fact in general it is not going to be
zero
so uh and this is rather
important okay so many people make this
mistake that
uh just because we are working under the
plane stress conditions
uh we should not be thinking that
epsilon z that is zero it is only
the sigma z sigma zx and sigma yz
that are zero all right
next for epsilon xy
we have 1 by twice g
sigma xy and
since g is equal to e by
2 into 1 plus nu this becomes in terms
of
the poisons ratio and the young's
modulus 1 plus nu by e
sigma xy
then sigma xy is going to be a function
of only x and y this epsilon xy
is also going to be a function of x and
y only similarly for the
previous three components of strains
they are all functions of only
x and y next for epsilon y z
since it is solely dependent on sigma
why is it like this
this is going to be zero because sigma y
z is zero
and finally for epsilon zx similarly we
have
the sole dependence on sigma zx and
since that is zero
the epsilon zx is also zero
so
one important thing as i've already
mentioned is that all the strain
components
okay all the strings are independent
offset
this is very very important
so these are the simplifications
involved uh
in the constitutive law so i should
write this
constitutive law
next let us take a look at what are the
simplifications
involved in the stress equilibrium
equations
as a result of the plane stress
considerations
so
and just to keep things simple for now
we'll consider
a situation where there are no body
forces involved later on we'll see
what changes we need to make
or we can make where body forces are
involved
so right now just for the purpose of
illustration
let us take this kind of a situation
so these are the stress equilibrium
equations
del sigma xx del x we have written this
a number of times
earlier del sigma xy del y plus
del sigma zx or xz
del z body forces are zero so the row b
extern is zero
now you see this term is zero okay under
the plane stress condition
already there is a simplification next
we have del sigma x y del x plus del
sigma
y y del y we have written this a number
of times earlier
i'm sure nobody will have any problem
with this uh
del sigma y z del z is equal to zero
and again this under plane stream
condition the uh the sigma y z
is zero another simplification and
lastly for the third component
of the equation we have our del
sigma zx del x
plus del sigma yz del y plus
del sigma z z l
z equal to zero and now you see
this sigma z that is zero the sigma y z
is zero and the sigma zx is zero so this
last equation is identically satisfied
it's a zero by zero form okay
so this is basically zero equal to zero
uh zero equal to zero not zero by zero
it's a zero equal to zero form so
basically we have these two equations
so del sigma x x del x
plus l sigma x y
del y is equal to 0
and del sigma x y del
x plus del sigma yy
del y is equal to zero now these two
equations
are very very interesting well first of
all
they're interesting because they're also
very simplified from the original three
equations
now we have uh from these from these
three equations where we had uh six
components six independent components of
uh stresses involved now we have two
equations
and three stresses three three uh
stress three independent stress
components involved sigma xx
sigma yy and sigma xy
now uh one of uh
people who who took a look at these
equations early on
so back in the 19th century
so they had some clever ideas regarding
solving this equation
because you note that ultimately our
goal here is to utilize these equations
uh
to actually solve some problems okay so
that's why we are
simplifying from this 3d theory to this
2d theory so we can actually solve some
problems
in a somewhat simple fashion okay so
towards that end of actually solving
problems
uh suppose one uh goes by the
root of directly using the stress
equilibrium equations
to start solving for the stresses what
can one do
well someone very clever by the name of
arie back in
back in 19th century uh uk
uh had a nice plan okay so had a nice
idea
so his name was arie and what he said
was that suppose suppose we
come up with a general form for this
sigma
xx uh sigma yy and sigma xy
such that these equations are
identically satisfied
if these equations for such general
mathematical forms of the stress
components are identically satisfied
then we can say that whatever we derive
from those mathematical forms
subsequently
they are going to be such that the
stress equilibrium equations
are always always satisfied okay so
these are very important
uh this is a very very uh
simple and straightforward idea but a
very very important idea so let's take a
look at what
uh aries idea was
so so this approach that we are going to
take
in his honor it is named as the airy
stress function approach
because the mathematical form that we
are going to write
that is in the form of a stress function
or what is referred to as a stress
function
so what is said was that suppose we take
the sigma
xx is equal to del square phi
del y square sigma yy
is equal to del square phi
del x square and
sigma xy is equal to
minus del square phi del
x del y where you please note
that this phi is some
general function of x and y of course
with the property
that the second order derivatives that
we have written down here
they are actually viable they are
admissible
uh as long as phi has those properties
that is a function purely of x and y
and these second order derivatives are
allowed
and if you substitute these forms back
in the stress equilibrium
equations it's too uh sorry about that
this two-dimensional
stress equilibrium equations you will
see that
these are identically satisfied okay so
these things okay substituted
in
the stress equilibrium equations
identically satisfies them
so this is such a simple idea okay these
these forms are so simple yet this
serves such a uh such a great purpose
that the stress equilibrium equations
the fundamental stress equilibrium
equations which follow from
if you remember our discussions from the
stress chapter
they basically follow from the
requirement of the balance of linear
momentum
within which the balance of mass is
embedded
the balance of uh of angular momentum is
in
its embedded because we have taken the
stress tensor to be symmetric
okay so all of these things uh together
are satisfied
just by taking this thing okay it seems
almost magical too good to be true
okay so whenever anything seems to too
good to be true
you you be a little bit careful okay so
there is
uh so despite this this magic kind of
solution
there is a need to be a little bit
careful here so what is this carefulness
we are talking about
well you see it's all fine that
these particular mathematical forms are
going to satisfy the stress equilibrium
equations great
but we have to remember that
as far as the mathematical forms are
concerned
there is no other restriction other than
that they should be
differentiable up to up to the second
order okay that's what all that all the
required
now this is a rather dangerous scenario
from the mechanical or the physical
point of view
because you see suppose i take rather
arbitrarily such a form
which does satisfy these kinds of
differentiability requirements
but uh in the process
it gives me some string
fields which are not compatible okay
because we have seen in the kinematics
chapter how
important the the the necessity of
satisfying the compatibility equations
is
they are necessary because without uh
if the strains are not compatible then
it may
give rise to some kind of weird uh
displacement fields
okay so
we have to be really careful about them
so
so what we write here is that but we
must be careful
in
choosing by
otherwise
uh or let me just reframe that
we must be careful in choosing phi
the reason is that
for some arbitrary choice of phi
it may turn out
that the
trains
are incompatible
okay so this is a dangerous
that we must be always always careful
about
okay so this is a real danger here
i've marked out with this girl mark
so we we understand that we have to be
careful okay
so understanding something and
implementing something or two different
things how do we go about
implementing okay after we have
understood that we have to be careful
so the way that we go about
making sure that the phi that we choose
will be such that the strain fields
are not going to be incompatible is by
actually embedding within within our
mathematical framework
the the compatibility equations okay
so this is ensured
by actually
including
in the
mathematical framework
of the
airy stress function approach so in this
entire approach
which we call the head stress function
approach and we are going to study this
in detail
what we do is
we include the by actually including in
the mathematical framework of the air
stress function
the compatibility equations
okay so this is the part where we
stop this uh this particular
lecture and in the next part of the
lecture we are actually going to go
about
including this compatibility equations
and proceeding further
with the air stress function approach
okay so we have made a start here and we
are going to continue with this
in the next part of the lecture thank
you very much